you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
sky news analysis shows a lack of
investment in the power supply could be
contributing to the energy bills crisis
at least 20 people are killed and tens
of thousands left homeless in madagascar
as the second tropical storm in less
than a fortnight strikes land
and some of the world's biggest
businesses are accused of only cutting
40 percent of the carbon emissions they
need to meet their own net zero targets
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now critics and mps have been quick to
blame the uk's ambition to cut carbon
emissions to net zero for the energy
supply crisis which has seen our fuel
bills soar
but analysis by our economics editor ed
conway has found that a stagnation in
global investment in renewable energy
could be making the problem worse so
let's take a look at our data dashboard
now and see the current energy supply
mix and as you can see we've got
nearly 40 percent of our energy coming
from renewable sources today so here's
ed
have net zero an environmental policy
contributed to the current energy crisis
it's clear
to us all uh that to keep uh 1.5 degrees
uh in reach
we need to consign coal to history
and make clean energy our future
that was quasi-core tanks pledge at
cop26 and our energy mix is getting
cleaner but our bills are also getting
bigger are they too related well this is
the typical bill once the new price cap
comes in a couple of things probably
already leap out i'll just kind of break
it down so you can see the constituent
parts by far the way the biggest part
over there is wholesale costs that's
international gas prices but there are
some environmental costs as well within
the policy costs area about eight
percent of bills so not enormous but not
trivial either but here's the thing
these are largely a consequence of the
past renewables used to be much more
expensive than other forms of power and
this is one way of looking at that this
is the energy cost over the entire
lifetime of the plant so you're talking
about over decades and a few years ago
this is how it looked back in 2009 wind
and solar far more expensive than fossil
fuels but just look at what's happened
since
by 2021 look at those bars wind and
solar we're cheaper
than gas or coal it's extraordinary but
we're still paying the price for those
earlier expensive years when those bars
were a lot higher you see the point here
but it's worth just noticing something
else that's important these bars are the
average cost over a few decades with
fossil fuels that's mostly well fuel
like gas and coal for the boilers but
with renewables the wind and the solar
power are free but most of the cost is
up front and if we look specifically at
those upfront costs just look so same
thing we're looking specifically at
capex upfront cost and just look at how
much more expensive wind and solar
are now both of those are valid ways of
looking at kind of the same thing but
here's why this version matters if we
were really serious about net zero you'd
expect to see evidence of this in the
numbers we should be expending enormous
amounts right now but is that happening
well if we have a look at global
spending on primary power in recent
years you can see it rose up to about
2015 so rising rising rising had it
carried on at that rate it would have
kind of gone up in line with that trend
but look at what's actually happened
it's essentially stagnated that line has
basically gone flat and for all the talk
about getting to net zero it's not
obvious that governments and companies
have been spending quite enough the
government has quite high ambitions for
offshore wind 40 gigawatts by 2030 um
but actually we're not yet on track to
get there so we do need to be seeing
greater investment in renewables over
you know particularly over the next five
to ten years
you see it's not quite the story you
might have expected is net zero
responsible for the current energy
crisis well maybe a bit it's lifting up
global demand for our gas lifting our
bills a little bit but the real problem
is we don't seem to be spending enough
on energy and that could come back to
haunt us
at least 20 people have died and tens of
thousands left homeless after cyclone
batseri struck madagascar residents had
barely recovered from the impact of
storm anna less than two weeks before
batsurai made landfall on the country's
southeast coast on sunday near the city
of mananjari
the category 4 cyclone brought winds of
up to 103 miles per hour which has
uprooted trees and destroyed buildings
in several towns and cities across the
coast well the worst affected areas were
maninjare mahanoro and nosy verico with
rows to the towns and cities being cut
off by debris
preliminary reports from the united
nations office for the coordination of
humanitarian affairs suggests that over
69 000 people are currently displaced
our africa correspondent john sparks has
this update
it will take weeks to make a detailed
assessment of the damage done by cyclone
batsirai
but the people of this island nation
know more than most about the power and
unpredictability of the climate
this category 4 tropical storm moved
over madagascar's eastern shore on
saturday evening and left a swathe of
debris and misery behind it
search and rescue personnel are still
struggling to reach some towns and
villages but preliminary reports from
government officials put the death toll
at 20 with some 70 000 displaced from
their homes
it's the second time in two weeks that
this nation of 30 million has been
battered by a major weather system
cyclone anna brought heavy rains and
extensive flooding to madagascar in
january and claimed the lives of 58
but batsirai has compounded the damage
with winds of 165 kilometers an hour it
shredded roofs and toppled brick walls
and residents of the coastal town of
mananjari say it has been largely
destroyed
the main road linking the islands north
and south has been badly damaged but aid
agencies did have some time to prepare
placing tens of thousands in emergency
shelters before the storm hit
the cyclone has now left madagascar and
will dissolve its thought over the
mozambique channel
but the people of this storm and
drought-riven nation are unlikely to
forget it
and we'll be talking more about the
increasing impact of extreme weather on
vulnerable communities in just a few
minutes in our panel discussion so do
stay with us
now for some of the day's other climate
news making headlines and south korea
has decided to fine mercedes benz for
false advertising gas emissions of its
diesel passenger vehicle the korea fair
trade commission said mercedes had
tampered with pollution mitigation
devices by installing illegal software
the antitrust regulator says it will
fine the german car maker 20.2 billion
won which is more than 12.5 million
pounds mercedes says it's cooperating
but will not be commenting further at
this time
new housing developments built on former
farmland are adding hundreds of
thousands of extra car journeys to
england's roads a new report has found
car dependency is increasing as typical
new greenfield homes are designed around
a car with it being impossible to reach
essential services such as shops schools
and doctors on foot or by bike
total rise in sea levels that would
occur if all the world's glaciers melted
may be 20 less than previously thought
melting glaciers contribute around 25 to
30 percent of current sea level rise but
the total amount remains unclear due to
a lack of ice thickness observations
now analysis of net zero pledges made by
some of the world's biggest companies
suggests that many are failing to meet
their own targets a report by the new
climate institute finds that they're on
track to cut their emissions by only 40
on average not the 100 promised by their
net zero targets the study looked at the
emission reduction targets of 25 global
firms including amazon nestle google and
unilever
many of the companies analyzed though
have rejected the findings and they
questioned the report's methodology well
climate action director at the charity
business in the community goodryn
cartwright joins us now from westbury in
wilkshire so welcome to you
so as we were saying many of the
companies say that the findings aren't
fair so do we have a framework by which
you can compare companies promises with
their action is there transparency out
there goodwin
so i would say the main
initiative is the science-based targets
initiative and and they recently
released guideline guidance on net zero
and the british standards institute is
currently
developing a standard but i think this
is all very new and companies are really
building the bridge as they walk on it
if we think about the level of
transformation we need to get to so the
uk carbon budgets calling for um three
quarters more than three quarters of a
cup by 2035 based on 2019
um it's hard to imagine what that could
look like so figuring it out and the
steps to get there um
is really difficult and i think one of
the things that's important is that
research that we did recently at
business in the community shows that
almost half of uk companies do not have
a target or an action plan and they're
not seeing it as a priority create to
create one
so we need to look at how do we
encourage more and appreciate what
companies are doing even if it's not
perfect so that we get more to step up
and what about those companies that are
making statements about going green
there are members of the public who
perhaps increasingly want to make green
choices themselves so how can they make
sure that a company's not just doing it
because it's popular but they're doing
it because they're actually taking
action
yeah and i think it's it's a really good
question i mean we know our research
also showed
that people want companies to act but
there's a low level of awareness of what
companies are actually doing
on the other side of the coin there's a
lot of reporting going on to all sorts
of different initiatives and
organizations
so there's clearly a gap between
the uh reporting and the communications
being easily accessible
and i think it comes round to the fact
that this is a huge um
you know challenge it's very tricky and
it's complex and it's messy and a lot of
the puzzle pieces they're just not there
yet you know companies don't know
exactly how they're going to get there
so being able to communicate that well
is quite hard as well
so we're recommending that companies
start to involve and invite people to be
part of their processes of designing and
delivering
to help people understand um
the you know the the complexities and
and how you make it happen
because we can't do it alone no company
can do it alone it's got to be all about
radical collaboration between all of us
to to make this happen
gudrun cartwright thanks very much
indeed thank you
now our weekly food shop can have all
sorts of carbon intensive products in it
without us even knowing in the latest of
our series of climate diaries we hear
from oda an online grocer which has
started telling customers the
environmental impact of their purchases
[Music]
the retail side is only five percent of
the total emissions of groceries 95 is
in production so to really make a
difference
for the climate we had to help our
customers make better choices
[Music]
so we have seen
the the share of red meat decline after
we
implemented the
climate receipt
[Music]
of course this is a function both of the
climate receipts we believe and also the
general trend
but it looks promising so far
[Music]
we believe that that using climate
recipes will be more prolific in the
future this is something that customers
care about it's also very important for
the climate
if we can change
how we eat that can have a massive
impact
on greenhouse gas emissions
do stay tuned coming up on the daily
climate show i'll be joined by climate
justice activist daisy ghadji and deputy
president of the national farmers union
stuart roberts and we're going to be
discussing how consumers can best make
informed climate choices
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
climate justice activist daisy gargi and
deputy president of the national farmers
union stuart roberts so good evening to
both of you nice to see you both
so first of all corporate net zero
pledges have a long way to go that's the
clear message from today's report into
various companies targets for carbon
neutrality some big names were
criticized as we heard earlier and
they're companies that many of us buy
from or interact with on a regular basis
but this is all complicated stuff so how
are we as consumers supposed to know
what we're dealing with how can we make
informed choices
so days this report does suggest that
there are some big companies out there
that aren't as green as they profess to
be the companies are saying that's
unfair so how does a consumer work out
how to make a green choice if they want
to when they're purchasing something
i think we've all seen this before where
companies are saying that they care
about things but clearly they don't
because a lot of the time their
ambitions are not ambitious
nor do they even follow up for them so
there is that kind of complication but
the real answer to how can we as
individuals make green choices is that
we can't um and that's the reality and
the reality is we're in a world with
very long supply chains supply chains
are unknown and are actively kept away
from us so how can we make sustainable
decisions we can't because we don't have
the information and this is kind of why
instead of focusing on what every
individual can make i ask for collective
policy decisions that can make sure that
companies can actually create products
that are in the lines of ethics that all
of us stand behind
stu do you agree with that as consumers
we have very little power to make green
choices and we need to rely on a
framework that companies have to follow
in order to make sure that their
offerings are green or at least it's
transparent
look i think transparency really helps
us here i think daiser talked about the
complex supply chains and as a primary
producer if you like the first step in
those supply chains the closer i can get
to the consumer the closer consumers can
understand what i do on my farm how i'm
contributing to net zero is really
important and i think too often i think
the big scandal at the moment is the
whole issue of green washing i'm seeing
way too much of this i'm not seeing
people make the the deep cuts we need to
in terms of fossil fuels and i'm not
seeing many other sectors of the economy
stepping up
as i know agriculture is and farmers are
and i think there's still a long way to
go well yes and days this report is
critical of some companies they they
think they're over using this idea of
carbon offsetting perhaps planting a
forest for example so that it allows
them to pollute a little bit more but is
that such a bad thing given there's so
much deforestation and given that trees
can play an important part in tackling
climate change do you think they're
right to be criticized for using that
tool
i think it's very easy to say that
you'll plant a couple of trees as you
continue to pollute the world that we
live in um i think there should be like
an active effort to stopping the harm
that you're creating first and then
thinking of offsetting later
and even when we start talking about
tree initiatives there's a whole grace
phase of if it's not properly done it
can actually cause more harm to the
environment than good um or even for
example the delayed effect of carbon
sequestering it's not within the first i
think some people say 16 years
of a tree being planted before it can
actually start sucking up carbon
effectively so these are the kind of
loopholes that they're using but this
could actually lead us into a place of
unknown and of uncertainty and that's
particularly quite scary it's true i've
seen a lot of head nodding from you
there i mean do you feel that farmers
are affected by this are you seeing that
some farming land is being bought up to
to plant trees and is that such a bad
thing
absolutely and i think it is a bad thing
the wrong tree in the wrong place is is
the wrong thing and for me i am seeing
many situations where uh land is being
taken up by by individuals or by uh
corporations to green wash their
emissions
and at the same time that process is
removing uh family farms people who've
farmed lands for generations and land is
in a limited resource we have to use it
to share
food production and all the other things
we want and at the moment i'm seeing
this this green washing actually taking
away from food production whereas we
should be looking at how we do food
production alongside doing our bit for
climate change as well
okay let's move on to our next topic
shall we because the indian ocean nation
of madagascar has yet again been hit by
extreme weather this time a cyclone
displacing many thousands of people now
we reported from the island not long ago
because of a devastating drought which
has affected huge sections of the
population and these disasters are
happening far away from us here but is
there a message
is this what's coming for us as the
climate change problem continues and
days what do you make of this i mean
obviously
it's a terrible situation for the people
living there but does news of events
like that in places as far away as
madagascar move the dial here do you
think as far as awareness of climate
change is concerned
well i hope it does i think a lot of the
time people forget that
living in the uk we are literally an
island we are very similar to madagascar
in certain senses and we do have the
same vulnerabilities um so there is this
like question of like remembering our
own situation in the world but then also
i think
the reason why a lot of people tend to
not really relate to the harm that's
being caused in places like madagascar
the harm that's being caused in places
like europe is because historically
there's been a devaluing of life in the
global south and when this happens this
means that the natural disasters that
are happening there that if it was
happening in germany we may have empathy
for a lot of people don't give space to
that which is an issue we need to get to
a place in society of where knowing that
someone is suffering and knowing that
someone is hurting is enough for us to
act here regardless of whether it feels
physically close or not stupid do you
agree with that
i i do i i daze speaks with real
authority on this but i think also for
me
let's not pretend these extreme events
aren't happening on our doorstep you
know only two three months ago now i was
on farms in the north of england where
we were seeing uprooted trees we were
seeing destroyed buildings we were
seeing people without power for a long
time and if anyone wants a reminder
about you know climate change being real
impacts both at home and the disastrous
impacts in places like madagascar are a
real uh
shout for everyone a real live call
and are precisely why every single one
of us needs to do our bit to address
climate change well yes and could it
make a difference amongst politicians do
you think days i mean we saw at the last
cop summit in glasgow the vulnerable
nations pushing for more money to adapt
to the effects of climate change that
they're already experiencing do you
think if we see more events during the
course of this year they'll get more
money when it comes to the next cop
well hopefully there are there is money
to cover the loss and damages that are
being faced by these countries but then
also i don't think that our politicians
should be waiting for more
chaos and and hurt to happen before
acting and i think this is where we have
to call on ourselves as active systems
within this democracy
and basically say enough's enough and
say we want to protect all people all
life and we want our governments to put
these policies in place because
a lot of the time people forget that
within democracy the sovereignty and the
power is held within the people and if
we say we need this the government
should be acting accordingly
okay well we must leave it there days of
gargey and stuart roberts always
interesting to get your thoughts thanks
very much indeed for your time tonight
thank you
so that's it for me but uh tomorrow i'll
be joined by deputy director at the
energy and climate intelligence unit
sepi golzari monroe and the journalist
and author david wallis wells do stay
with us coming up next on the great
debate we're asking can you afford the
cost of living crisis that's up next but
for me thanks for watching i'll see you
next time
[Music]